joining me now for reaction from Dallas
is Republican Congressman John Radcliffe
and here in Washington is Byron York a
Fox News contributor chief political
correspondent for the Washington
Examiner and Victoria tensing a former
Justice Department official in the
Reagan administration great to see all
of you we got a lot to get through guys
let's start with you congressman the boy
that Democrats were coming at you guys
with everything today basically saying
this is a big dud that you're
endangering law enforcement and they're
still keeping up with the methods and
sources you're endangering methods and
sources what's your reaction to the
cavalcade of criticism that poured all
over the airwaves today well Laura good
to be with you I have to laugh that you
know the comments coming from Adam
Schiff about protecting classified
information the irony of that is not
lost on a lot of folks in Washington who
are convinced that he's a graduate of
the Edward Snowden school of keeping
secrets you know I understand why the
Democrats would be upset with what they
read in that memo today but it doesn't
change the outcome of what's in there
and as you know Laura I'm one of the few
people that have seen the underlying
source documents and having had that
opportunity to review those I feel like
they're very consistent with the memo
that the public was able to see today
that was drafted by the majority members
of the House Intelligence Committee all
right I want to play for everybody the
question posed to Devon Nunez tonight by
Bret Baier about that issue of the
underlying applications let's watch did
you read the actual Phi sub applications
no I didn't the agreement we made with
the Department of Justice was to create
a reading room and allow one member and
two investigators to go over and review
the documents I thought the best person
on our committee would be the chairman
of the Oversight Committee trey Gowdy
who has a long career as a federal
prosecutor to go and do this in other
words Viki they were going he was going
off half-cocked the Democrats are said
he's got off hair he didn't read the
thing and he's pushing this memo I guess
that's where the devil but that's what
was just following the rules that the
Justice Department mandated in order to
give them the documents those are always
negotiated what bothers me most about
what you've seen today with this memo oh
there's so many things but the first
thing is that McCabe said that they
would not have sought they would not
have even gone to the VISAA court unless
they had that dossier that just is
really scary and then the bootstrapping
of course the dossier was used to put in
a story to plant a story with Michael
Isikoff his journalistic [ __ ] he just
takes whatever the left gives him and he
rewrites it I'll work it on the same
team though aren't them in the media of
course this whole thing they're all
they're all helping it's a boosting
Society one's boosting everyone else's
narrative a very aggressive lack of
curiosity on the part of the journalist
to say well who would you get this
information let me look at the
underlying Byron you're the first person
to uh to get this memo it looks like in
the media one of the person did I guess
as well but what Vicki just said about
the issue of of what they knew when they
knew it
what what stands out for you especially
the McKay point the deputy director of
the FBI
well they said that the memo says that
the dossier was an essential part of
this of this application and as Vicki
said they it goes on to say that that
they wouldn't have done it without the
dossier and I've been told they're
really four things that they cite as the
reason for this warrant it's the dossier
it's that Michael Isikoff article it's
the Papadopoulos case mine is correct in
Yahoo News is this the Papadopoulos case
and it's Carter pages history but what
I'm told is the dossier was by far the
biggest of all of those so it was
absolutely essential and it really
supports this idea that if without the
dossier there's no application and
George papadopolis I mean what the heck
was he doing bragging in a bar the the
some the Hillary's emails were going to
come out soon then the Russians were
going to do it is that reason for him to
be put under abotobble it's one of the
most ludicrous things I've heard to base
anything on congressman the the issue
the ago had I was just going to comment
on the clip that you played there Laura
about Devon Nunez decision
why wouldn't you send over trey gowdy
why wouldn't you send over the best
lawyer in congress a lawyer who has
viewed hundreds if not thousands of
agent declarations affidavits and
submissions to federal courts why
wouldn't you send a guy who knows
exactly what he's looking for what would
pass the smell test and what wouldn't I
think he ought to be applauded for that
decision
hey congressman are you going to move to
push to release all these underlying
transcripts redacted as necessary of
course but the Democrats are trying to
kick up dust in your face now saying oh
wait well McKay wait that's not accurate
McCabe didn't say that and his
closed-door testimony that they wouldn't
have gone after the FISA a warrant
without that dossier
there's disputing that tonight on other
networks so we need to see that
transcript I know Byron wants to see it
yeah I think transcripts of witness
interviews
those can be redacted and made public I
think the Democrat memo the minority
memo ought to be made public to I will
tell you having read that Adam Schiff
drafted that and it's chock-full of
sources and methods so it's gonna have
to be heavily redacted before it's a
made available to the public methods
that they complained about getting
compromised that's interesting I will
say this about the underlying documents
that I've been able to review you know
it's hard to take for phone books worth
of information and distill it down to
four pages so I think it's fair when the
FBI director says not every material
fact is included I think that's a fair
criticism so but as someone that has
reviewed the underlying documents the
story ends the same way about you taking
things out of context the Democrats are
saying we need the whole context you're
missing key key facts that would inform
why this warrant was applied for when it
was applied for you reject that I reject
that as you know Laura I'm a former
terrorism prosecutor I have significant
experience with FISA I've looked at
these applications before and I just as
I as I looked at the underlying
applications I
kept coming to the same conclusion I
wouldn't make these representations to
any federal judge much less a FISA judge
if you were a FISA judge wouldn't you
want to know if someone was asking for a
warrant and we had to get to borrow in a
Vic here but my question to you is was
there something in that application that
referenced a political motivation for
the dossier the Democrats we got slow
well was over talking about that today
so that was he said that was in the
document in the application not not
mentioning Hillary by name but that
there was a political motivation was
that in there well I don't know why
Eric's wall wall would know that because
he hasn't a Keynesian question was it in
there did they reference a political
motivation for the dossier in the
application well I can't disclose
anything specifically that's in the
underlying document what I can again
reiterate is it doesn't change my okay
got it got it Byron okay I want to play
this we got to play this on Nunez hinted
that there's more to come that this is
just the tip of the iceberg and
revealing DOJ FBI corruption let's watch
other other memos that are going to come
out
are there other memos you said this was
phase one yeah so this so this completes
just the FISA abuse portion of our
investigation we are we are in the
middle of what I call phase two of our
investigation which involves other
departments specifically the State
Department Byron what do you know well
that's interesting that he says the
State Department because we have had
indications recently that there is some
sort of involvement of the State
Department not as much as the as the FBI
but we know that John Kerry the
Secretary of State was briefed on the
contents of the dossier so that means
the staff knew about it as well so
there's there's another phase and I'll
tell you another phase that should
happen the FISA Court would get it
better get busy because they're either
incredibly grossly negligent thank you
or they were lied to and don't you think
they should care and shouldn't they have
some kind of a hearing a process okay
could you could the Carter page even
with sovereign immunity concerns could
sovereign page
file in court an action for abuse of
process or sanctions against Justice
Department attorneys for emitting a
material fact in a FISA application is
there any grounds well he could file
something with the DC bar he could do
wherever these Precog remembers of the
bargain file he's filed a case in New
York he did it pro se so it's not you
know I haven't
that's a cold hard case homies former
chief of staff Chuck Rosenberg was all
over television today and he said look
if they really had concerns about this
if the Trump people or the Republicans
were worried about this they they could
have gone to the Inspector General in
voice their concerns and he said they
could have gone to the privacy and civil
liberties oversight board and they could
they could go to the FBI that's what he
said today commis mouthpiece was oliver
MSNBC I think that just ignores the
political urgency of all this because
there will be an inspector general
investigation of the handling of this
and it's going to come out in 2020 or 21
or so that'll be too late are saying the
damage will have been done but there are
people who want to remove the president
from office based on this case we have
to know what the evidence is